I'd like to welcome you to today's
briefing I'm joined by Jenny Harry's the
deputy chief medical officer he'll be
sharing with you the latest detailed
data on coronavirus on any normal Sunday
afternoon many of you would have been
out with your family and friends
enjoying the sunshine and tomorrow many
children would be going to school for
the first time after a two-week break
but these are not normal times and we're
asking you to stay at home so can I
start by thanking you for all the
sacrifices that you've already had to
make and that you continue to make I
know this has not been easy
but it is a surest way that we have to
protect V NHS and to save lives I can
report through the government's ongoing
monitoring and testing program as of
today four hundred and eighty two
thousand and sixty three test for
coronavirus have been carried out in
Great Britain including twenty one
thousand six hundred and twenty six
tests carried out yesterday a hundred
and twenty thousand and sixty seven
people have tested positive there's an
increase of five thousand eight hundred
and fifty cases since yesterday eighteen
thousand one hundred and eighteen people
are currently in hospital with
coronavirus in the UK compared to
eighteen thousand and six on the 17th of
April
and sadly of those hospitalized with the
virus sixteen thousand and sixty have
now died there's an increase of five
hundred and ninety six five fatalities
since yesterday we mustn't forget that
behind every single statistic there is a
heartbreaking story
and my sincere condolences go out to
everyone who has lost someone that they
love these are challenging times for all
of us and each of us has a role to play
in fighting this virus those who are
working in the NHS those doctors those
nurses there's clean as those porters
those ambulance crews they're all doing
an amazing job they're truly heroic in
the part that they're playing and
supporting every one of us in this
nation but today I would also like to
say how enormous ly grateful we are for
those who are working in our nursery
schools colleges universities and
Children Services and profoundly
grateful for the vital role they're
providing in our communities they've
been keeping schools and nurseries open
including over these two holidays so
there's our most vulnerable children and
children of critical workers can
continue to be supported and they can be
cared for people are anxious to know
when we're going to relax relax
restrictions when schools are likely to
be fully back and open again of course I
want to nothing more than to see schools
back get them back to normal
make sure that children are sat around
learning and experiencing but joy of
being at school but I can't give you a
date because before we do we need to
meet five tests first we must protect
the NHS's ability to cope and be sure
that it can continue to provide critical
care and specialist treatment right
across the whole of the United Kingdom
second we need to see daily death rates
from coronavirus coming down third we
need to have reliable data that shows
the rate of infection is decreasing to
manageable levels fourth we need to be
confident that
Steen capacity and PPE is being managed
with supply able to meet not just
today's demand but future demand and
fifth and perhaps most crucially we need
to be confident that any changes we do
make will not risk a second peak of
infections when we can be sure that we
have met these five essential points we
can think about getting children into
schools again learning mastering new
ideas and being with their friends once
more we will work with a sector to
consider how best to reopen schools
nurseries and colleges when the time is
right our first priority has always been
protecting the well-being of children
and young people but particularly those
vulnerable young people with special
educational needs or a social worker
schools are open for them and we're
working to make sure those who should
attend do so places are available for
children of critical workers to with up
to a hundred and thirty thousand
children in school every single day
schools are helping to keep the country
moving and we're asking our local
authorities and schools to ensure every
vulnerable child knows that their school
is there to support them their systems
are in place to keep in touch with those
children who are unable to attend
because of health reasons I know that
families of seriously ill and disabled
children are particularly worried at
this time and I'm grateful to all staff
who are working so hard to support their
education health and care particularly
those in special schools and residential
care homes young people who have left
care or just about to whether that's
from the foster family or residential
care
a really vulnerable right now so I'm
asking local authorities to ensure that
no one has to leave care during this
difficult time for 1.6 billion pounds of
additional funding announced yesterday
will help local authorities give care
levers and other vulnerable groups for
support that they need at this difficult
time to further protect children from
harm we're continuing to support child
line and working with the NSPCC to
expand and promote the adult help
helpline by providing them with an extra
1.6 million pounds this means children
have someone to call and more adults
will be able to raise concerns and seek
advice about the safety and well-being
of any child that they're worried about
like the rest of a population all our
teachers have had to adapt very quickly
to new ways of working they've had to
move resources online work remotely
change the way they support their
students as well as one another I'm
immensely grateful to them and to
everyone who has offered their support
including those who have made resources
freely available for schools parents and
pupils to use we have already published
a initial list of high quality online
educational resources including how to
support physical and mental well-being
and materials for teaching children with
special educational needs and
disabilities in yet another example of
how we are at our best when we work
together some of our leading state
schools have collaborated to open the
oak national academy which will be
launched online tomorrow this is a
totally new initiative led by 40
brilliant teachers who have assembled
video lessons and resources for any
teacher in the country to make use of if
they wish to do so
180 video lessons will be provided each
across a broad range of subjects for
every year group from reception through
to year 10 I recognize all the
challenges that families will be facing
at the moment and we determine to
support parents who are helping their
children learn from home I think we all
know how difficult that can be
but BBC has developed resources for
families as part of the most
comprehensive education package in the
BBC's history available on TV and online
from tomorrow morning and to make sure
as many children as possible can access
online learning we're ordering laptops
to help disadvantaged young people who
set key exams next year we will also
provide laptops and tablets for those
children with social workers and care
leavers
to help them stay in touch with the
services they need keeping them safe as
well as supporting home learning and if
disadvantaged secondary school school
pupils and care leavers who are
preparing for exams do not already have
internet connections will provide free
4G Reuters to get them connected while
schools are closed we're also working
with major telecommunications providers
to exempt certain educational resources
from data charges so that this does not
add to household expenses that may
already be very stretched at this moment
before I finish I'd like to applaud the
remarkable way our education community
has responded to this outbreak and the
normally proud and inspired by the
incredible spirit they are showing
schools are supporting their communities
in every way from preparing food parcels
to sharing their facilities with local
hospitals colleges are manufacturing and
donating equipment and universities are
working flat-out
develop diagnostic tests and of course a
vaccine which will help us beat this
invisible enemy and to any young people
watching I wanted to say to you how
sorry I am that you've been disrupted
you've had your education disrupted in
this way I know how hard it must be and
I'd like to thank you for making the
adjustments that you've had to make I
know that you'll be missing your friends
your teachers your lessons and I want
you to know that you are such an
important part of this fight - and I
cannot thank you enough for all that you
are doing this global pandemic is the
biggest threat to our country it's the
biggest threat that this country has
faced in modern times if we all continue
to work together as we have been and if
we continue to stick to the advice of
our experts we will come out the other
side and be able to begin the task of
rebuilding our communities